what are you so happy about I'm in bad
shape I have a whole warehouse full of
its muller time t-shirts does anybody
I've got extra lard they're at a
discount rate and my avenatti 2020 ones
are completely tight they are tanking
but no it's been a week right in a week
I think we're all a little confused I'm
confused I mean Mullah released this
board it was a week ago tonight it was
right before we went on the air and he
did not draw a conclusion on whether
Trump tried to obstruct justice but
wasn't that what Muller's job was to
draw a conclusion on obstruction it says
so right in the report we're not allowed
to read
yeah we're not allowed to read the
report but if we have a new faith based
justice system Trump's Attorney General
and I do mean Trump's Attorney General
William bar read the report for us you
know this is like trying to pick a
restaurant and the only yelp review is
from the chef we can't see the report we
can't see Trump's taxes can't even see
his grades it's like bizarro world Obama
the only thing we have seen is this
birth certificate that's the whole thing
just I don't know it doesn't quite make
sense to me at this point it's like one
of those movies you know where they seem
to be wrapping it up seems to be over
case closed we caught the killer and
then you click wait there's 15 minutes
left but right I feel like there's a
final scene where Muller goes home and
he puts his briefcase down he sits down
to dinner with his wife who is Roger
stone
he's cooking of meat law police talking
on the phone in Russian to Vladimir
Putin you know so Trump also had a week
now to absorb the new realities of the
post Muller world and he used it as a
starting point to call for a renewed
sense of unity I'm [ __ ] kidding of
course
he went apeshit and lied his ass off
about how he reportedly exonerated when
the report specifically said it does not
exonerate him yes the pregnancy test
came back negative it doesn't mean
you're a virgin
oh of course he immediately went on and
I got away with trees and tour he was in
Michigan last night they were chanting
four more years he he did his greatest
hits
you know lock her up drain the swamp
build a wall he even went to no one
thought I could go 270 electoral votes
here's one phrase you'll never hear from
Donald Trump stop me if you've heard
this before they launched into this
thing I'm the elite one I have a better
education I'm smarter I went to better
schools this is the President of the
United States five award beautiful house
Dave of Greenville parties literally
said and I'm president and they're not
that's when I started chanting four year
old for you
and then he went after Adam Schiff I'm
just saw Adam Schiff speech that he made
in Congress one of the great speeches I
think of all day it sounded like
something lawrence O'Donnell wrote for
the west wing I mean it was pretty
awesome so obviously Trump is mad and he
of course responded intellectually I'm
joking again he went right to that got a
cold
Adam Shipp a little pencil little pencil
neck Adam Schiff he is the smallest
thinnest neck I've ever seen this is a
burn to his base he's thin what a loser
who uses pencil neck it's 20 90 wouldn't
even use pencils in 2019 there's like
something a bully would say in a little
rascals movie and now Congressman Jeff
is too classy to respond in kind so I
will I'll say it for him I'd rather be a
pencil neck than a mushroom dick okay
okay so after all this madness right in
the middle of a Trump comes out and
tweets the Republican Party will become
the party of health care and the rest of
the Republicans are like we will and my
favorite he said this week we're going
to send humans to the moon by 2024 who
wants to break it to him we already did
this
you